[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar accelerating strain development
process for cdmo and cro companies
i am kayleigh bach of lab roots and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by inscripta
to learn more visit inscripta.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker eric
abate director applications and
development at inscripta
eric you may now begin your presentation
so today i'm going to tell you about a
high throughput genome engineering
platform that we've developed at
inscriptive and how it can be used to
accelerate strain development for cdmo
and cro companies
so first of all what are cdmo's and what
are cros
so a cdmo
is a contract development and
manufacturing organization and this
provides really a comprehensive service
all the way from research and
development to commercial manufacturing
so overseas a large part of the product
development process
a cro is a contract research
organization and this provides r d
services or outsourced r d services
so both cdmo and cro companies are are
very important to the bioeconomy
particularly in recent years where
companies are moving towards more of a
leaner business model and because of
this it requires much greater reliance
on external partners to do certain
aspects of the product development cycle
and this this importance has really come
out of the explosion in the biotech
space
and this has led to a dramatic increase
in the number of products in development
and this is not only true for larger
companies that are also
testing out or trying to develop
many more products than they have in the
past to have many more opportunities for
success as well as dramatic increase in
small biotech companies
that have been popping up over the years
companies are interested in managing
their r d costs again towards this
leaner business model
and then also to address capacity
constraints so even large companies who
have their own internal manufacturing
capability
due to the number of products they're
trying to develop at once they don't
have the necessary capacity
to do scale up testing for all those
and then also to have access to
innovation so in in biotech there's
continuously
dramatic increase in innovation and
technologies that are coming out
and companies want to have access to
that innovation but they don't
necessarily want to bring that
innovation in-house
so they will outsource some
research r d that needs to be done
to outside companies who have expertise
in this new
areas of innovation
also for small companies uh in-house
development of scale capacity is very
resource intensive and it can also cause
a shift and focus away from some of the
core competencies of these small startup
companies
but these large companies and small
companies need to have access to
productive and efficient strains that
can be scaled up
so there's a lot of challenges in
developing these production strains that
can be used for for manufacturing
various different products
and when i discuss this right now i'm
going to focus
mainly on say protein production
but this can also be applied to
nucleic acid production or even small
molecule production
and there's really two areas that are
sort of challenging
for for production strain development
and they kind of break down to either
yield or manufacturability
so on the yield side you can have issues
such as low expression or no expression
of your target protein or small molecule
low solubility of the protein this is
often due to incorrect folding or
misfolding of the protein
you could have degradation
by host proteases that are expressed
by the production strain
the protein or small molecule could be
to could have some toxicity towards the
production host
you can have secretion issues if the
protein is being secreted secreted from
the organism so you can get it can get
tied up in the secretion pathway you can
have inactivity of the enzyme
and this could potentially be due to
post-translational modifications that
that might be important for the overall
activity
on the other side
you have things that are related more
towards manufacturability so yield is
important but it's not everything for
manufacturing
so you have to have a production strain
that is tolerant to the product whether
it be some sort of enzyme or a small
molecule
if you're working with bacteria you can
you care about endotoxin levels and that
that final
product so this is particularly
important in the biopharma space or in
the food area
so you might want to develop strains
that have lower endotoxin levels
again for bacteria phage resistance so
phage contamination could be a huge
problem that can
basically destroy a production run so
developing strains that are more
resistant to phage would be beneficial
ultimate product stability so after
manufacturing
and downstream processing you care about
having a product that is stable
and
changes to the host strain can have an
impact on that product stability
and then also you need to have a strain
that has a
good
fermentation properties so it basically
you know grows well in fermentation
tanks
so these are kind of some of the main
challenges from a yield and a
manufacturability point of view
and several of these challenges can
really be overcome by scalable host
strain engineering
so to optimize the development of
production strains we really need high
throughput tools to make diverse edits
uh genome wipe
and there's a lot of tools that have
been developed over the last several
decades
that allow for strain engineering to
take place
and if i plot some of those tools that
are developed and
put them on this axis or this matrix
over here
where on the y-axis you have a variety
of edit types from low to high and on
the x-axis the number of genomic
locations from low to high
simple things like gene knockouts or
gene knock-ins is a
simple edit type and also you're
targeting maybe one location
something like classical meteogenesis
where you treat a production strain with
a chemical mutagen you can introduce
tens to hundreds of different edits or
changes within the genome but it's a
very low variety of edit types that you
can introduce
if you're doing something like classical
protein engineering in this case you're
targeting maybe a single enzyme
and
but you can have a variety a wide
variety of edit types so
a few number of genomic locations but a
high
edit type and what you really want to do
in order to scalable genome engineering
is to get up in this quadrant over here
targeting a large number of genomic
locations with a high variety of edit
types and really crispr genome editing
has allowed you to get up into this
quadrant
but in order to have its full potential
you need to have a tool
to build very large libraries in a high
throughput manner
and towards that end i would like to
introduce you to inscripto's onyx
platform which allows for programmable
and trackable variation
to be introduced into e coli and yeast
so the two microbes that we are
currently supporting on the platform
and the onyx platform really supports
all areas of the design generate test
learn cycle
and this is really the
basis of the scientific method
so it all starts um in design where we
have an easy to use web portal for
design and ordering of editing libraries
and this is the software package is
called designer and it allows a customer
to go in and
design whatever changes they want to
make within e coli or s or vca
and you can make thousands of different
edits
within that organism
but one edit per cell but you can make a
population of cells of thousands of
different
different strains
after you've designed your library or
after you've designed the edits you want
to introduce the software itself does
creates optimum designs for introducing
those edits that initiates the
manufacturing of the reagents and the
consumables that are necessary to build
that library
once those reagents and consumables come
in you put them in another aspect of the
platform which is the onyx instrument
itself which is shown right here
you put those consumables into the
instrument along with the cells you want
to introduce
the library into and you press go
and in a completely automated hands-off
way the instrument takes care of
building that libraries which takes
anywhere from two to four days to build
it depending on if it's e coli or s
cerevisiae
so after two to four days you get a tube
of edited cells that come out of the
instrument
within this tube each cell will have at
most one of the edits that was designed
within your library but again up to
thousands of different edits
and
that
pool of edited cells can then go into
your phenotyping workflow inscripta also
provides dna sequencing kits that allows
you to determine the quality of that
library that you've built
and then also genotyping kits that after
you've done your phenotyping which could
be a selection workflow or a screening
type of workflow allows you to do dna
sequencing on those uh that hit
population or those individual hits
that ngs data then gets fed into another
software package called resolver and
this is what determines the edits that's
contained within those hits or the
distribution of edits within your hit
population
and this basically allows you to link
the genotype to the phenotype
then you'll probably want to take a hit
strain from that first round and go
through this cycle all again and you can
do really rapid
rounds of genome engineering
using the onyx platform
we like to call this um the onyx
platform really a genome engineering
biofoundry on your benchtop
it creates optimum designs using the
designer software it utilizes the
proprietary mad 7 nuclease crispr
nuclease
designs per library for e coli anywhere
from 100 to 10 000
or yeast anywhere from 100 to 6 000.
there's a single edit per cell
you can have a diverse
edit types anywhere from one to six to
63 base pairs in length
and you can precisely deliver edits
either genome-wide all over the place or
at specific target sites within the
genome
you can track the edit in every cell
with barcode and gs so there is a dna
barcode that's associated with every ed
edit that allows you to do rapid
genotyping by sequencing that barcode it
has push button simple workflows
and it really democratizes genome
editing and i i like to use myself as an
example so prior to coming to enscripta
i had never designed a library certainly
never built a library but i had
phenotype to library
but using the onyx platform i'm able to
come up with an idea
i can very rapidly use the designer
software to design that library
then i can build that library using the
onyx instrument
and once i get that pool of edited cells
i can immediately go into my phenotyping
workflow
so there's a wide diversity of edit
types that can be introduced in both the
coding and the non-coding regions
so in the non-coding region you can
imagine targeting regulatory
regions within a protein so this
includes maybe the promoter or the
terminator regions
you can target the coding region of the
genome we always like to do genome-wide
knockout libraries we do this by
introducing a triple stop codon at the
five prime end of a gene or all genes
you can also do saturation mutagenesis
where you mutate one residue of the
protein to all other
possible residues
so here's some more of the specs about
the platform so as i mentioned the hosts
that are currently supported are ecoloy
and srvca this includes enscripta
standard strains and related customer
strains
you can target the coding and the
non-coding regions in the native genome
or if you've introduced heterologous
sequences you can also
target those for editing
designs per library e coli up to ten
thousand s cerevisia up to six thousand
you can have one edit per cell
but you can do insertions you can do
deletions and you can do substitutions
anywhere between 1 and 63 base pairs
the library composition that typically
comes out of the instrument after your
library build
typically greater than 90 of designs are
contained within that library of the
original
designs for your design library
and the edit fraction is anywhere from
15 to 75 percent depending upon the
difficulty of the edits that you're
trying to introduce
as far as time reagent delivery is
approximately three weeks and library
build is anywhere from two to four days
but your hands-on time with the
instrument for a library build is really
less than an hour
so the onyx platform really accelerates
scalable
genome engineering and strain
development so how does this whole
process work so it all starts with
building a base strain this is where you
introduce your heterologous gene or
heterologist pathway
into your production strain
you develop a phenotyping workflow in
order to assess
the production of a compound or protein
then you build a library on top of that
or multiple libraries on top of that and
we'll get some examples of how you do
that and what type of libraries to do or
use
and this is really where the strain
optimization takes place you use the
onyx platform to build a library
you phenotype that library you select a
strain to go into the next round
you take your hits from your first round
and start combining them with one of the
hit strains to combine diversity
and then you can go through this cycle
multiple rounds
in a very rapid fashion and the honest
platform really decreases the cycle time
by up to 50 percent because it the
bottleneck at the design and build stage
um is dramatically reduced
and then after you've gone through
enough rounds to develop a production
strain with sufficient um titers or
quality
then that selective strain um can go
into for production
so the onyx platform gives you increased
access to the strained genome for making
precise changes and this accelerates the
product to market timeline because you
can go through these iterative cycles so
rapidly
and increased sampling of novel variants
can lead ultimately to better product
performance
okay so i'm going to give you some
examples of where we use the onyx
platform to improve
a strain that can be used for production
of two different proteins
and really heterologous protein
production is central to many different
industries
and this at its core has is this based
on this concept that you can use
microbes as sort of mini cell factories
in order to produce massive quantities
of proteins to be used in say industrial
biotechnology space biopharma or
therapeutics
a really hot area right now is this
alternative protein market
or applications in the in the
agriculture space as well
so the first application i'm going to
tell you about is what we wanted to try
to improve the production enzyme called
cvh1 which is important for the
industrial biotechnology space and we
decided to use yeast as the host for
this
so cbh1 is uh stands for
cellobiohydrolysis one it's an important
enzyme in the degradation of cellulose
and in fact it's the
the most important enzyme in that
degradation process
cbh1 is important for a process called
cvp or consolidated bioprocessing
and the cbp process has this idea that
you have a strain that produces a suite
of enzymes that are necessary for the
degradation of some type of feedstock so
you mix this strain with this feedstock
the feedstock is often waste plant
material lignocellulosic plant material
so the enzymes that are produced by this
strain
excuse me degrade that feedstock
producing sugars the cells then or that
strain will take up those sugars and
then are able to
convert that into some sort of fuel or
some sort of chemical that can be used
for an industrial application
so we decided to focus on a fungal cbh1
that was codon optimized for expression
in yeast
we used the natal native signal sequence
the native fungal signal sequence
and we drove expression of the gene
using the yeast the native yeast eno2
promoter
so the base strain was built in senpique
and we generated a single copy genomic
integration of this expression cassette
so the assay is pretty simple and
straightforward it was using a pnp based
substrate pnp beta lactoporanoside
substrate cbh1 hydrolyzes this bond
right here releasing para nitrophenol
which has a characteristic absorbance of
405 nanometers and by using an enzymatic
activity assay we're able to quantify
the amount of active cbh1 that is being
produced
our screening workflow was all done in a
high throughput manner using automation
um the
micro fermentations were done in 96 volt
plates using 300 microliter of media
and to show you a little about the noise
in the screening workflow
if i pick 96 colonies of the base drain
and take it through the entire workflow
we have a cv of about 1.7 so very low
noise which allowed us to identify cbh1
overproducing strains with even small
improvements in cvh1 production
okay so now we had our base strain and
our screening workflow
so
now comes the fun part where we build
libraries on top of
the space drain and try to improve the
production of cbh1
and we had lots of different concepts
that we came up with of trying to to
improve production but it really broke
down into two different
overarching themes and those are using
an unbiased approach where they're more
genome-wide libraries so targeting all
over the genome and then targeted or
rational libraries
so for the genome-wide libraries we
generated a genome-wide knockout library
which had about 5 100 edits contained in
that library
a genome-wide synthetic terminator
insertion library
this is where we took a synthetic
terminator and inserted it at the three
prime end of every single gene
in yeast and ultimately this can have an
impact on the overall expression of that
particular gene we also generated a
genome-wide deletions library where
there were deletions anywhere from 1 to
59 base pairs and these were spread
throughout the genome
targeting either regulatory regions or
within the
open reading frames themselves
so that's the unbiased libraries
as far as the targeted libraries or
rational libraries we had two libraries
targeting the eno2 promoter that was
driving expression of cbh1
this includes
insertions or deletions of
the native transcription factor binding
sites located within the eno2 promoter
or swapping in other transcription
factor binding sites
at different locations within the
promoter
i generated a cbh1 alternate codon
library and this is really a site
saturation synonymous mutation library
where you take every codon and change it
to all other codons that encode the same
amino acid
so basically what we're trying to do was
code an optimization
in the context of the gene integrated
into the genome
and then um i have another library here
that's called the targeted knockout
library and what i did for this library
is i mined the literature looking for
genes that have been previously shown
that when you knock them out they
improve the production of a heterologous
protein
i also did a genome-wide protease
deletion library so host proteases can
often be problematic for heterologous
proteins
and then i targeted some genes in the
glycosylation pathway which might have
an impact on secretion
of the proteins
so these are the all the different
concepts that we wanted to test in total
there were seven different libraries um
which broke down into this unbiased and
rational approach
so this is a summary of all the first
round um screening work that was done as
i mentioned there were a total of seven
libraries
between those seven libraries there were
15 000 different edits
targeted
and i screened 8 500 isolates from these
different libraries
they were all screened in a primary
workflow where each isolate is screened
as a singlet hits that we identify then
go through a retest workflow
where those hits are
retested in quadruplicate to confirm
that their indeed hits and get some
better measurement of the improvement
that we're seeing
in total there were 136 confirmed hits
that we identified from these seven
libraries
and 74 of those hits were unique
so what i'm showing here is um what
happened or the data from the first
round the primary screening data from
the first round the second round and the
third round so that first round
really provided the diversity that was
used in subsequent rounds of
iterative genome engineering
excuse me and i'm showing here the full
improvement over the bass drain
so
right here is the you know one fold
improvement so this is the base strain
activity
here are the seven different libraries
that we identified in the first round or
that we screened or built and screened
in the first round and it was very
satisfying for us to see that we saw
nice hits um from all of these different
library concepts so all the concepts
that we came up with we're able to
identify hits from them which is really
satisfying and nice for us
so i took two hits from the first round
and those went into the second round
i stacked either a genome-wide knockout
on those two hits or i took all the hits
from the first round designed a new
library and stacked that on top of one
of the hits and that's what went into
the second round which i showed here
very nice for us to see that in our
second round screening again we're able
to identify hits with a significantly
improved cbh1 production
i took the top hits from the second
round right here
that went into the third round of
screening where again i took that first
round hit library and stacked on top of
that hit
from the second round which gave us the
the screening the primary screening data
for the third round again it was very
satisfying as to see that we
continuously see improvement in cvh1
production through these three rounds of
iterative genome engineering
okay so that's the first sorry the
primary screening data now what i'm
showing you is the retest data for all
the hits that we identified from the
first round the second round and the
third round and i'm showing you the full
change in
improvement
in production over the bass drain and i
arbitrarily picked about a 10
improvement
as a minimal hit or a minimal
improvement in cbh1 to define it as a
quote-unquote hit in our screening
workflow
and you can see again here that from the
first round to the second round to the
third round we're continuously improving
ch1 expression these error bars here
show
the standard deviation of quadruplicate
measurements showing that there's very
low noise in the assay and that these
strains are indeed improved over the
previous round hits
okay so we had done a lot of unbiased
approaches so genome-wide knockout
terminator library
deletions across the genome from the
first round and then a genome-wide
knockout stacked on first-round hits
and i was interested in looking at what
are the genes that we identified from
this unbiased approach and is there
anything interesting about them
so in total there were 69 different
unique hits from the first and the
second rounds that were identified in
these unbiased approaches
and when i started to categorize them by
different functions or different
cellular processes
i found something interesting so there
are lots of genes targeting the protein
degradation pathways
protein trafficking
several stress response the most were
actually in transcription translation
processes nuclear transport a couple in
the glycosylation pathway 10 of them
didn't really fit into any particular
pathway and they were kind of spread
through various different cellular
processes
it was also interesting to note that we
identified hits in 11 genes of unknown
function
so if we had taken a purely rational
approach towards building these
libraries we probably would have never
or we certainly we personally would have
never targeted genes of unknown function
but because we also took this
parallel unbiased approach this allowed
us to pull out hits that we would have
never identified from a purely rational
point of view
it was also interesting to note that if
you were to think about trying to
improve protein production and where
bottlenecks might arise
these bottlenecks would be in all of
these different processes protein
degradation protein trafficking stress
response transcription and translation
glycosylation pathway all of these
processes are things that touch
heterologous protein production
okay
so the next thing that we wanted to do
was um to scale up
these um hits that we identified
from our different rounds into shake
flasks and in order to do that we took
three hits from each one of the three
rounds and we scale them up into 25 ml
shake flasks so we did our screening
work in 300 microliters but we wanted to
see can we scale them up to at least
shake flask
growth
so the first thing that we wanted to do
was to measure the growth curves um
for these different strains relative to
the base strain which is shown here in
black
and we were able to utilize um a
technology called a cell growth
quantifier that was developed by sbi and
what this technology allows you to do is
non-invasive continuous measurement of
growth
in a shapeflask or in other vessels as
well
and it does this by measuring the back
scattering from your your cell culture
continuously over time we went up to
whatever's 65 hours
in this experiment
so it gives you nice detailed growth
curves
and you can see here in black this is
the base strain which interestingly had
the highest amount of growth
and all of our different strains that we
identified from the three different
rounds which i'm not going to go into
the details of which ones are which
the important point is that all of them
grew to up to a lower degree some of
them had shifted kinetics as far as how
they grew and then ultimately maybe
plateaued at a similar level some of
them had very similar growth kinetics
but then plateaued at a much lower level
it was interesting that all of them had
decreased growth relative to the base
strain
and this is kind of consistent with
reports in the literature that they find
strains that have improved heterologous
protein production often have lower
growth and it's speculated this is
likely due to the fact that carbon is
instead of being going towards cell
growth more of that carbon is being
diverted towards the production of
proteins which can be you know carbon
intensive
okay so this is what the growth curves
look like for all the different variants
but now we wanted to see what does the
cvh1 production look like
the more important thing again these
three hits from each round were grown in
25 mil shake flex cultures using the
same media conditions that were used for
screening
and this is what the data looks like
so we're able to look at the absorbance
of 405 nanometers again this is a
measure of the amount of active cbh1
that's being produced
over time
i'm showing the base strain here in this
black dashed line at the bottom
it was very nice for us to see that the
three first round hits first round
strains that we picked um all produced
at cbh1 levels that were
better than the base train
our second round hits are right here
again improvement over the first round
hits and then our third round hits were
further improved over the second round
so it's very nice to see
that all of the hits that we identified
in our small scale screening that we
scaled up um they all translated to
larger scale and in fact these were all
the hits that we we tested at larger
scale and they all ended up translating
to at least 25 mil
shake flash culture
and the top hit that we identified here
had about a four-fold improvement in
cbh1 production over the base string so
a significant improvement in production
okay
so that's a little bit about the type of
improvement you can get so we saw in
this particular
project we saw a four-fold improvement
after going through three rounds of
iterative genome engineering
now the question is well how long does
it take to do that how quickly can you
do it and what type of resources as far
as fte resources are involved
in doing that
so here's again a schematic of the
overall
workflow so you build your base brain
you design your library you build your
libraries your phenotype and genotype
and then go through this cycle multiple
times
so the first round screening
this included seven libraries as i
mentioned we identified 74 unique hits
from that this whole process took us
about three months
and i will say most of that time was
spent doing the phenotyping because the
design and the building aspect has been
completely de-bottlenecked to where that
is really a small portion of the time
for the second round which is a
genome-wide knockout stacked on a
first-round hit that was about one and a
half months
and the third round which was a round
hit on top of the second round hit that
also took about one and a half months
again most of that time being spent on
the phenotyping workflow
so in total in about six months time
span we're able to develop a strain with
a four-fold improvement in protein
production by going through these three
rounds of iterative genome engineering
the final strain is having
three edits contained
within that production stream and of
course you could keep going through this
cycle multiple multiple times or many
many more times
to further improve the cbh1 production
as far as the amount of time
as far or resources as far as people
resources involved
so designing a library takes anywhere
from you know
a single person anywhere from a half an
hour to a few hours per library
depending on the complexity it's a
simple genome-wide knockout you can use
designer software very rapidly allows
you to do that but if you want to design
more complicated things like targeting
the eno2 promoter um that will take a
little bit more
time as far as
off
or outside of the designer software in
order to to design those libraries and
upload those libraries into the designer
package
as far as build the hands-on time is
really less than 20 minutes
to start a run
and the run time is
in this particular case is four days
per library for cnpk
and the phenotyping and genotyping which
is really the most labor intensive part
was about .25 ftes in order to go
through that part of the workflow
so overall you're able to develop a
strain with significantly improved
production and phenotype
um in a
short period of time using really
minimal amount of resources in order to
do that you really don't need an army of
scientists to do this type of project
okay now i'm going to switch gears and
talk about another project
that we worked on
where we wanted to improve
the production of a gene called or a
protein called asparaginase b
and this is really important for the
biopharma and therapeutic space and we
decided to do this in e coli using a b
strain
so the enzyme asparaginase is involved
in the conversion of asparagine
to aspartic acid
and ammonia
and this enzyme is actually important
for
cancer therapeutics
so
it had been identified that several
cancers are unable to produce asparagine
and they really rely on the asparagine
that's circulating within the blood
so if you were able to find a way to
degrade that asparagine in the blood or
convert it to some other compound in the
blood you could then starve the cancer
cells
for this important amino acid that it
needs for growth
and that's what was developed is
this asparaginase is actually
a candidate with broad use
in in various cancers including
acute lymphocytic leukemia which has
about 6 000 new cases per year
however
there are some improvements that need to
be made with this asparagine asb
and a lot of them focus on production so
you need there's a need for improved
production and purification of this
important enzyme and then also to
overcome production toxicity so this
asparaginase
is somewhat toxic to e coli
overproducing it in particular is toxic
okay so the same type of workflow that
we use for cbh1
the first thing that we did was we
inserted the asparaginase gene within to
the e coli genome
then
we designed different libraries against
that base strain to produce edited cell
library we tested them in isolating
isolate measuring asparaginase activity
so that goes into phenotyping workflow
then you can do rapid dna sequencing by
the barcode
um identify those hits and then you
could go through multiple rounds so i'm
only going to show the data from one
round of this asparaginase genome
engineering that we did
and again we we fell back to these two
strategies to generate diversity and
you're going to hear this over and over
again and we use it for many projects
where we wanted to do an unbiased
approach which is genome-wide libraries
and then we also wanted to do a rational
approach which is targeted libraries
targeting genes that we think might be
important
for heterologous protein production in e
coli
so we did a genome-wide knockout library
knocking out every gene in e coli this
was about 4 000 edits contained within
that library
and then we did a genome-wide promoter
insertion library and in this case
excuse me we took a strong synthetic
promoter
um so promoters pictures have a strong
increase in transcription and we
inserted that in front of every gene
in e coli
so those are our unbiased approaches
again just genomic
then we had a targeted library
and the one targeted library i'm going
to talk about is a what we're calling a
cell morphology and protein folding
library
and what was targeted was various
different chaperones
that can have an impact on
the folding of proteins
proteases um that obviously can have an
impact on the expression of the protein
because it can degrade your heterologist
protein can be degraded by host
proteases
and then genes that are involved in
morphology of the cell
and these different gene classes were
targeted with a couple different edits
so a knockout library or knockouts of
those genes
various different promoters that were
targeting those genes as well as well as
truncations of those genes
so those are the two
library approaches again this unbiased
and then a rational approach
so with e coli and depending on what
strategy you're using
you can actually go through this design
generate test learn cycle quite rapidly
and it can be anywhere from two to four
weeks depending on if you're using a
library that might be off the shelf so
like genomic knockout libraries we
routinely have those available so you
can very rapidly take your hit strain
and stack a genome wide knockout library
on them
but anywhere from two to four weeks to
go through this design generate test
learn cycle
for this particular project
somewhat faster than yeast
so i'm showing the um
the primary screening data from these
three different libraries
showing the fold improvement um over the
median which is here at one
we did pretty shallow sampling of only
441 isolates from these three different
library concepts but it was very nice
that they were able to see some hits
that had an even
greater than two-fold improvement
in asparaginase activity
so again
looking back at the cbh1 story looking
at what type of cellular processes
are these genes that we identified as
hits what what cellular processes are
they involved in
we saw five
cell membrane genes
we saw six stress response genes so this
again is not necessarily surprising
because heterogeneous protein production
can be somewhat stressful um to an
organism as well as we know that
asparaginase itself is somewhat toxic to
e coli the cells grow much slower when
they're over expressing asparaginase
we also identified six genes of unknown
functions so we see this repeated theme
over and over again again because we
took these two strategies of rational as
as well as unbiased approaches it
allowed us to pull out these genes of
unknown function that we would have
never identified with a purely
rational strategy
and then we also identified
five genes that are proteases or
chaperones again you know completely
making sense for heterogenous protein
production
okay so as far as conclusions
so the onyx platform really enables
rapid stream development for improved
production for cdmo and cros or for any
other company that wants to develop
production strains
it can increase the yield ultimately of
that product
through various different
library concepts and various different
cellular processes that you might touch
on
that the libraries might touch on
and then also from a manufacturability
standpoint where you can decrease say
product toxicity or overcome
productivity like we did for the
asparaginase project and you can imagine
designing libraries for e coli where
you're trying to decrease the amount of
endotoxins that are being produced
or ultimately end up in the final
product or decrease the
or increase say the tolerance
to phage
or any other
strain property that is important
towards um
scale up to production scale
the platform also allows for rapid
workflows for significant reduction in
both time and resources necessary to
optimize production strains so i talked
about you know for
s cerevisiae for cbh1 it was about six
months to go through three rounds with a
four-fold improvement
and for asparaginase it was about say
four months four weeks or so to go
through this first round and you can do
that in in just a few weeks to go
through these cycles
and it also requires minimal amount of
ftp fte resources because we've really
de-bottled neck the amount of time
spent and and
resources or people resources that are
spent doing the design and build aspects
of these design build test learn cycles
and the ability to sample greater
amounts of diversity genome-wide really
provides more shots on goal in
identifying strains with better
performance
because you can make these very large
libraries very rapidly you have more
opportunities of identifying hit strains
that can have that improved
performance
and also you know one of the issues or
one of the things you care about when
you're going from high throughput
screening small scale
up to
say lab scale fermentations where the
conditions are very different in those
two
at those two different scales the
concern is always do your hit scale up
because the conditions are so different
and because you're able to identify many
hits in this high throughput screening
workflow by building much larger
libraries it gives you more shots on
goal on identifying strains and hits
from your small scale that will
translate into larger scale
fermentations
and with that i'd like to thank you for
your time and attention and i'd be happy
to answer any questions that you might
have
thank you eric for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
all right let's get started our first
question here asks can you talk about
generate step more in detail
uh yes so i think um that's in reference
to the actual building of the library
which happens on the instrument
so i can give kind of a brief overview
of what happens
um
on the instrument during the build
process
but i would also encourage you to look
at some really cool videos we have on
our encrypted website there's a nice
video called um onyx instrument tour
that goes through all of the steps in a
little bit more detail
but basically for the for the generate
or what the generate part or what
happens on the instrument is you put
the consumables and reagents onto the
deck along with the cells that you want
to introduce your library in you press
go the door will close
um the instrument takes care of every um
step within the process so it first
grows up your cells
um to a proper od that makes that be
good for um making them competent uh to
do a transformation
um so it grows them up it makes them
competent
for doing the transformation
then it mixes it with the dna that's
necessary to build the library does the
electroporation recovery and then it
goes on to a specialized
microfluidic module where the editing
process actually takes place
then it harvests those cells off of that
module collects it um into your cell
output tube um and then
at the end of the run you take that cell
output tube and then that's what goes
into your phenotyping workflow
that's kind of the basics of the steps
involved in the build that happens on
all the instrument
great thank you
next question here is it challenging to
develop this platform for other
organisms um such as pikia pikia excuse
me
yep
um yep we get that question a lot um
so
as i mentioned you know the the platform
currently supports e coli and s
cerevisiae as the two hosts there's we
definitely hear lots of interest in
other um organisms so pikia is one of um
one of the ones that we hear and um
bacillus is another one that we hear
potential customers interested in
as far as it being challenging i don't
know if i would say it's challenging but
it definitely requires some development
work in order to
optimize the platform
you know there's a lot of work that has
gone into getting optimized design
scores for e coli and for sara vca as
well as um
the the dna architecture that's
necessary um for for getting that
process to take place uh efficiently
within the within the microorganisms so
i don't know if i would say it's
challenging but it does take some
development work um in order to or it
would take development work if you
wanted if we wanted to expand it to
other organisms
great
next question here what was your overall
expression titer of ansb in grams per
liter
yeah that's a good question so we
actually haven't measured um the the
absolute titer um for the for the
asparaginase um
the work that we've done has all been
basically in in small scale
um
high-throughput screening
um so i don't know what
you know what that would translate to if
you went to larger scale fermentation
but we actually we haven't measured um
the absolute titer uh yet
for these strains but good question
great thank you
next question here you said that the
cbh1 gene was optimized for expression
in yeast why do you think you were still
able to identify hits in the alternate
codon library
yes so that was actually an interesting
library so it was based on a um idea
that i had kind of
wanted to i've wanted to test for quite
some time is to look at
you know when we synthesize um code
unoptimized genes is it really the the
most optimum
gene structure for that heterologous
protein
and i think the answer to that question
of why we're still still
able to get hits out is that we don't
fully understand
all of the steps in translation or how
codon usage really translate into
um
translates into the translation of the
ultimate protein so
um
i think one way to think about it is
you know there has been some reports in
the literature that you can actually
over code on optimize a gene meaning
that you can optimize it so that it
expresses so rapidly
that it doesn't have time to properly
fold
and if you
do you know complete codon optimization
that you can actually end up with less
active protein at the end so i think
that's a potential part of it there's
also um
you might imagine that
you might want certain places within the
gene where the ribosome might slow down
or pause for a moment by maybe
introducing a less
a more rare codon at that location and
that will allow for the protein to to
fold or what's been translated so full
so far to fold properly
there can also be differences in in trna
pools at different times during um
fermentation whether it be at the
beginning or the end of fermentation or
in mid-log phase so i think those are
some reasons why um but i think it is it
was very encouraging that we were able
to get some um nice hits out of that
library suggesting that there is still
some improvements you can get as far as
from codon
optimization of the gene
great
next question here do you think the
genome hits identified for both projects
will be generalizable to other proteins
or do you think that they are specific
to those proteins
yeah that's a that's another question
that's good so
the answer is we don't know at this
point
i think it would be really cool to do an
experiment where we test multiple
different genes
multiple different heterogeneous genes
in these different strains to see if we
see an improvement
i mean i can imagine that some of the
hits are probably going to be
generalizable if they're things like
you know overall secretion of any
protein or transcription or translation
or nuclear transport that might be
important
but i could also imagine that there's
certain hits that might be specific to
certain proteins so certain proteins
might have
specific bottlenecks say for proper
folding that other
heterologous proteins might not have so
i i think the answer to that question is
there's probably certain ones that are
generalizable to all proteins and then
there's likely other ones that are
specific um to certain
proteins certain heterologically
expressed proteins
great thank you
next question do you think that after
several rounds of using the first round
hits library and builds you will
eventually stop getting improved strains
yes so um
the answer to that question is yes i
think ultimately once you've
gone through several rounds of this
iterative genome engineering where
you're using the same you know the hits
that you identify from that first round
those different hits
might be
touching on different bottlenecks within
uh multiple pathways that are involved
in heterologist protein production and
once you've kind of combined all those
hits uh into a single strain you
probably um will kind of exhaust all of
the the diversity or the improvements
and diversity that you can get
and that's not necessarily the end of
the project because now what that means
is that there's probably bottlenecks
elsewhere
that you might need to uncover um and
deal with
and what you often do in these types of
um projects where you're doing whether
it's protein engineering or genome
engineering you'll go through a series
of rounds of combining your diversity
into a single strain
and then you want to start adding new
diversity and what you do is you you go
back to one of your say unbiased
libraries like a genome-wide library
genome-wide knockout library and start
adding more diversity again
to your library
and that would allow you to uncover
some new diversity that might have
improved phenotypes
great looks like we have time for one
more question here so we'll wrap up
after this one and this asks instead of
using a single hit strain for the next
round of iterative genome engineering
could you use a pool of strains for
building the next round
yes so the examples that i gave here
we used a single strain that went into
the next round
it is definitely possible to use a pool
of strains so maybe you take five hits
from your first round um and stack say
all the hits on top of that or or
genome-wide knockout on top of that
that's um entirely doable and in fact we
have a an app note um
or a tech note about that um where we
tested that very thing and it definitely
does work
there are some complications as far as
using the software
um the inscripta designer and resolver
software in order to characterize those
hits or those libraries that come out of
it so it's not quote unquote a fully
supported
workflow as far as from the you know end
to end solution that we're providing
with the platform but it's definitely
something that is doable um
on the instrument and we have done that
um and so if you're interested in more
about that i would encourage you to take
a look at that tech note
great well thank you again eric for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor in scripta for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care everyone goodbye
you